what's up guys this is eric griffin and
i want to give a big shout out to
helix sleep right take their two-minute
sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life
find the perfect mattress at
helixleep.com
griffin let's start the show okay
let's do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your
[Music]
favorite podcast
[Music]
welcome back guys one more time we're
gripping
today is gonna be all movie review
episode with a little catch up on my
life
um got some big news i got some big news
for you but uh other than that it's just
gonna be the same old eric griffin
same old weapon with griffin so i'm glad
you're here we're gonna be talking about
the snyder justice league
you know and maybe a little falcon but
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
all right anyways welcome back to river
with griffin everybody uh ladies and
gentlemen it's another week i had it was
birthday month
it's still birthday month march 12th was
my birthday i had a good time i'm having
a really fantastic birthday month so
beard is back i had to shave a little
bit last week
had this huge huge audition but first of
all thanks for being here so please
subscribe share like listen
watch this and also listen to the audio
i need i need your help every everywhere
i can do it uh i
got somebody that's actually going to
start helping me so we'll see if that
makes a difference
uh taking some of the load off and um
and you know we'll see what happens
we're still i'm still gonna do the
podcast and i got like another i got
something else in the works
in the podcast space so we'll see what's
going on and once again i'm always
gaming i'm on air griffin gaming
daily i don't know if i'm all if i'm
going to continue to be able to continue
doing it daily like that but i'm still
going to be
gaming and i have i'll have a schedule
once i if i can't do it daily because i
kind of just randomly come on and then
people come
you know whenever they can you know you
just catch me like oh [ __ ] he's
streaming live right now so
that's usually how that works so make
sure you catch me out there on eric
griffin gaming on twitch
and i usually put those videos up on
youtube all right
so uh anyways you know big birthday
month so
i i'm not gonna i can't i don't think i
can actually say
exactly what it is yet which is a shame
because i think they're gonna make an
announcement
they've probably made an announcement
today the day their podcast is released
but
either way in case they invented they
didn't i don't want to like you know you
know
be like oh this happened but i had a
huge audition
for a television show and it was a
whole big rig of a role man you know um
it was a network show and i i booked it
y'all i
booked it so as of right now i booked it
i mean i could be fired by next week who
knows
that's just how it works in the business
such a weird thing you go to the table
reading they go you know what i actually
don't like he's too tall or whatever
they could say
but anyways but for now it's exciting
i went through a whole thing with it you
know it's amazing how
in this business your life can change
with an email because i basically
got an email saying like you haven't
this is what happens you get an audition
your
agent sends you an email he's like
here's a audition it's a self tape
audition or whatever kind of audition it
is
this one happened to be an audition by
zoom
in front of like producers um you know
the producers and
creators of the show you know so i'm
like okay you know so then i get on the
zoom
i've got i set my room up you know in
the other room i set it up
i got the thing ready to go i'm ready
i'm ready to do this thing
and then like you know to say it was at
four o'clock 4 15 rolls around 4 20. i'm
waiting in the zoom lobby and i'm like
do i have the right thing i don't know
what's going on
and then the people all the people pop
on the screen hey eric hey eric hey
hey you know and then they are um
you know they uh they go okay are you go
ahead eric you know
you'll read with the assistant you know
all of us will mute and
and by the way this is different this is
you know the you know covet
auditioning because you don't understand
that there is something about
when you walk into a room and you're
auditioning in front of like
like i remember workaholics like i'll
never forget the workaholics process
okay so i went to the first audition at
workaholics it was in front of the
casting director
you know so it was like you know the two
casting directors and then
you know i did my audition i had
prepared for it because i i really
thought it was such a bizarre role and i
was like this montes who the hell is it
this is such a weird character i said i
really want to say these
weird things on tv so you know i did the
audition
and then like the casting director
looked at the other casting director and
they were like you know
maybe that's it you know and so and then
it was a long process after that
so the first time i went the first time
i met the boys i always i've told this
story before about whatever who cares
right
maybe this is your first time listening
to riffenwood griffin but like i went to
the audition
like a day ahead of time and i met blake
like blake's just walking through this
little office hallway and i'm like hey
and he goes
are you here for montez and i'm like
yeah he goes that's tomorrow then i was
trying to play it off like well you know
i like to come early
[Laughter]
so i went to the audition early but
blake always tells me that he went back
to the writers room and he was like yo
guys
i think i just met montez so that's just
a we you know that's all that
but you know even if it's if it's not
true you know we know what they say
don't let the truth get in the way of a
good story
so you know so anyways
the point i'm trying to make is you know
you i walked into the room now
and here's i'm meeting kyle i'm seeing
on
ander anders and i'm seeing blake and
you know and here's adam devine sitting
there who i didn't even realize
it was his show i thought he was just
like interning or something like that it
was so weird because i just saw him a
week before
you know anyways and so you have this
energy in the room though
you know when you know so you know
you're getting direction from the
director or you know the producers are
telling you kind of hey you know try
this whatever you're trying to get
and then you can kind of do the work and
you could see the response and i'm a
performer i'm a comedian so
i like that i like that interaction you
know so that's been taken away when you
do things over zoom
so now i'll cut two i'm doing this
audition and you know the
the it's just me and the the assistant
you know and everybody else
mutes their their thing and they mute
their mics they mute they turn off their
video and it's just me and her
i do it no feedback i don't know if it
was funny or not you know what i mean
because
by meaning i don't know if that's funny
because you hear this the laughter
so i do it you know i was pretty
confident in how i did it and then you
know
everybody comes back and they go oh you
know they're you know they're la they
stay clean oh you were so funny
thank you you know all right eric you
know i was like well should we do it
again
because that's another thing too is like
when you go in the room you want to do
it again
you want to give them another another
crack you know and
these people were like no we got it
thank you you know
so i was like well i had all this
lights and [ __ ] set up and i was like
well there goes that not gonna get that
one
you know and now i have this running
joke with my manager um
you know i call you know i always text
him he's like i go to auditions and i go
you know what what's because i always
want feedback what happened come on let
me know what's going on
he'll be like this is this the response
you get a lot they loved you
casting loved you you produ oh they
loved you but
but you know i loved they loved you bud
so this time so now i always go did i
get that i love you but yet
you tell me about the you know so this
time he goes
well they they said they loved you and
there was no butt
and i was like what okay so then they
just started this whole
process man of like okay so now i'm
waiting so then they want me to test so
when you
when you're about to do a network show
they have a thing called a test and the
test is basically
basically it's like they're deciding
between you
and two or three other people or how
many people they want and they're saying
one of you is gonna get the job so what
they do is they make you sign a contract
so they make you go okay we want you one
of you
so everybody has to sign a contract like
you're gonna get the job so you sign a
test contract
you know and it sucks because like you
know you see the money that you could
possibly make you know you it just
it's on your head there's nothing you
can do about it you know what i mean i
wish they didn't do that because you
know
but it is what it is so you know i
signed a contract and then like
now you have a test audition and they
would get it by zoom again
you know so i go i have it all set up
and i did it in here too
i did it in here i had a lav mic on i
got my good camera i made sure it wasn't
blurry because i know i'll be messing up
with the podcast sometimes because i hit
the wrong button
and then when you like hit the button it
auto focuses and then when it auto
focuses when nobody's sitting here
it's auto focusing say on this and you
know it looks blurry
so i realized i was supposed to press a
different button but who knows it may
still mess up
but anyways so i have it all set up i
have my you know things set up
you know i got it you know it's looking
good professional
and i do the test you know what i mean
everybody's laughing and then the thing
about the test too is like
they the producers and director and
everybody's there it's the writers
producers and they're giving you like
do it this way let's do it again but try
it like this so that's kind of cool but
you still don't get any feedback in
terms of laughter so i do that so i do
the test
i think i did good i really liked it you
know
and then i get a call like a few days
later and it's like hey
they want you to test again you know and
for me
i know what it is you know it's like and
this is a thing i think
a lot of comedians have trouble with
when they transfer into
acting you have this sort of like they
say you're too big you're not grounded
you know they want you to be grounded
meaning they want you to be more real
meaning they want it to feel like
doesn't feel like acting or pushing or
trying to be funny
they want you to be grounded they say
you know and i always have that problem
because when you're on stage you're a
comic you're being big
you know what i mean you're you're you
know i i'm i'm i'm i'm
i'm doing things for this big laughter
i'm a big i'm boisterous and
you know and i have all that sort of uh
energy but you can't be like that say on
a tv show and i learned that when i did
you know and then and then my original
first job ever
like tv job was montez workaholics and
he's
montez is like a [ __ ] nut bag you
know what i mean just
big and boisterous and all this kind of
stuff so everything i do after that you
kind of get typecast
you know you you know i had this one
casting director telling me one time i
went
and auditioned it was during workaholics
time and i go to audition he says to me
hey you know this isn't montez right and
i was insulted by that because i was
like uh
yeah i mean what do you think i'm gonna
do like that for everything i do ever
you know what i mean it was
it was insulting but at the same time i
understand i wish he had been like hey
it's not as big as my dad let's let's
make you know make it more grounded so
that's what they wanted for this
you know and because my tendency is to
like really like you know play up the
funny
so they wanted to do it again and then
like the
the um the the actress that's gonna play
my wife on the show
you know she's there we're reading
together
you know so they gave me some notes and
we did it again and they said oh we
loved it
it was like i really thought i killed it
i really did i was like i killed that
[ __ ]
you know and then i get another call
they want you to test again and i've
never heard of this before
like doing the audition three times the
third time they wanted me to shave
dye my beard no first they wanted me to
shave
so the first one to test i had i shaved
the whole beard i shaved the second test
i shaved the beard off they wanted me to
shave it off
they wanted to see how that looked the
third test they wanted me to dress a
certain way
they wanted the beard to be dark now
instead of shaving it off now can we put
some color in it
and it was like what and then they had
me dressed and i i put the picture up on
instagram it's like i never even i'm not
as cool as this character is supposed to
be apparently you know
but you know it's acting so you can
whatever your costume is it is what it
is you know
you know i had like a hoodie and i had
like a jacket over the hoodie then they
wanted my old glasses the horn rim
glasses and i
you know so i they wanted me to look
like this whatever
they their envision of the character
because they wanted the network to see
this is what he's going to look like you
know which made me feel like they're
like well i don't know
is he can he can he can he look a
certain way
is he going to is it going to look good
with those two or whatever the
their their apprehension was about me
these people wanted to show no no we see
the vision we want him to do it
which made me feel good so i did a test
for the third time you know
i did it and at first started i was a
little nervous at first
i realized you know but luckily in the
process
you know because we're filming it you
get to do it again and by the way i
think that's the best way to do it
i have auditioned for a sitcom before
where i got a test it was for dr ken
actually
i was going to be the nurse on dr ken
and it's funny because the guy that got
that job him and i were having an
argument
it was so stupid but we were having an
argument in the waiting room
you know about the gay parade i remember
i'll never forget we were having this
like
he was cl you know anyway i don't even
go into it but we had a stupid argument
it was like before the test it psyched
each other out right but he ended up
booking the job
um but here's the thing so normally when
you test you walk into a room full of
like suits
people who like you know the
entertainment business
let me tell you something about the
entertainment it's one of the few
businesses
you know of my limited you know
experience because i
haven't been in a lot of businesses but
this is what i know about this business
it's one of these businesses where the
people that run it
they're not very good at it meaning
they're not actors they're not
performers
they're not talented you know they they
they're just they're not creative people
they're just people that make choices
you know what i mean they write checks
so because they write checks they
want to make choices they want to make
decisions so you know i go
and i'm sitting in front of these people
but here's the thing it's a lot of
pressure
it's different so you walk into a room
and you have to do the audition
and i remember being nervous and i
remember fumbling the lines and whatnot
and this is like could change your life
so to me i always think why make it like
a one-man show
play that you have a one-and-done like
the ncaa championship or something
and you have to hit the shot right there
as opposed to like hey
let's record it a few times let's get it
the way it's gonna be like how when you
do the actual show
so you know it's it's a tough thing so
it's part of it like it weeds out the
week man
so you know and i've tested other times
too i tested for
another show when it was like i was
getting some odd notes from the director
producer
you know it's like the day before the
test you know the lead actor calls me
and he's like hey man
you know uh it was for cbs i remember he
was like man you know cbs wants you to
be
this grounded there's another word
grounded you know so make sure you know
you know it's like we don't want to be
too over the top we don't want to be you
know and i'm thinking to myself
so you don't want me to do all the [ __ ]
i've been doing to get me to the point
where you want me to be in front of the
network
so now when i'm getting in front of the
network you're telling me hey don't be
you
don't do all the things that we wanted
you for can you do this thing
it was so bizarre so i go i do it
you know i leave the room and then the
guys come out
the guy remember forget the producer
runs out eric listen
um we want you to do it again please go
in and do it again uh
all those notes we told you please
forget all those notes i'm like
oh really you mean so go do the thing
that makes people laugh
that made you laugh that made you want
me to do this you know it was such a
bizarre thing but of course
i didn't get to part the show didn't go
anyway so
whatever so you know
so why am i even talking about all this
it's because
the zoom is different but you know what
and i talked about this with jeremiah
watkins and he really brought this to my
attention
doing this is prepared me
for booking this show you guys have
helped me
doing this podcast gaming having this
equipment
knowing how to set it up being
comfortable being in my room just
talking to no one
and think in in knowing that i still
have to perform and make sure that
people that are listening
get it all this has prepared me
to be able to do a great zoom audition
and i
did it y'all and i booked that [ __ ]
booked it so hopefully when this comes
out you'll know as you hear this you'll
know what it is you'll be like oh
[ __ ] i just saw the the announcement or
whatever so but anyways
all right so that's uh the bigger thing
i wanted to talk to you about that you
know about the air griffin fan base
you know the you know we're small and
mighty but now let's get into what i
wanted this episode to be about anyway
what's up guys here to talk to you guys
about helix sleep
you know you got to go to helix sleep uh
it's probably
literally the best mattress i've ever
had you know especially
listen uh they make it easy though let
me tell you the best thing about here to
sleep is you get this sleep quiz
you take you take this two-minute sleep
quiz you put all your information in
it's like eharmony for you know you and
your mattress
i did that i'm a side sleeper so i
needed to be firm but not too firm and i
got the mattress on my dreams and it's a
really i'm telling you right now
i'm not just saying that because look
listen this is an ad right but it's an
ad because it's a testimonial and i'm
telling you this is the mattress you got
to get and i know it's a lot of things
going on right now in the world that
makes it hard to sleep with stress and
all that kind of stuff so
you want to have a good mattress that
helps you that helps you sleep helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2000
by gq and wired magazine alright helix
is offering up to 200 off on all
mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com
griffin hear what i said helixsleep.com
griffin and have the best sleep of your
life they're a great company and i
highly recommend it
i sleep on one you should sleep on one
too so shout out to healy sleeper
remember go to helixsleep.com
griffin for 200 off and some pillows
let's get back to the show what's up
guys uh
i want to talk to you guys about better
help um
listen i talk about this a lot i do
real-world advice from a grown-ass man
i give out advice and i always tell
people look i'm not an expert i'm not a
pro
and i encourage people to get therapy
it's great i've been to therapy
and you know it doesn't it doesn't solve
your problems necessarily that's not
what it's for but it does help you
organize your thoughts
make you understand the root causes make
you connect the dots
with a professional and that's what
better help is all about
you could start your communicating with
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely
online betterhelp is committed to
facilitate
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed
that's an important thing too because
sometimes you feel like oh man am i
stuck with this person no they help you
go hey
if it didn't work out with that one you
know what try another one because it's
all part of their service like
depression stress anxiety
how's your relationship doing listen man
we've been dealing with a lot of crap
for a year now and we're trying to get
ourselves back to normal
it hasn't been easy for people go to
betterhelp.com
all right in fact so many people have
been using better help
that they're recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states so that's
great to hear so they're continuously
adding professionals to help you guys
out
look guys i want you to start living a
happier life today
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting
our sponsor at betterhelp.com
griffin guys betterhelp.com
griffin join over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp h-e-l-p dot com
slash griffin for 10 off your first
month and let's get back to the show
anyway
i saw the zack snyder uh cut of
justice league all right and i want to
talk about
that way let me just look up some stuff
real quick so i make sure
yeah the snyder cut this snyder cut
of justice league all right so let's
talk about it
and i'm so into it that i even have
notes y'all
i wrote some notes down so i don't want
to be like a negative nanny
like when you're doing like reviews so i
want to give you the pros and cons
i don't know how we'll do it for go like
you know
both we could do pros first we could do
some pros some cons but
first of all let's say this now here's a
difficult part
if you first of all i think this movie
is a hot mess
i think it's a hot mess and i think it's
great all at the same time
and for a lot of reasons that we'll get
into right now so this is now the review
of the
the jack snyder cut of justice league so
one of the issues is have you seen the
original justice league
i have you can't unknow what you know
about that movie so your experience when
you're watching the new one
the snyder cut it is
that's a part of if you like it or not
because it it could be the comparison of
the two movies is what you like about it
or you know what they change the fact
that you know what happened
because my thing is if you just saw this
movie and you didn't see the other ones
i don't know if you're gonna like it
you know it's just it's it was a weird
movie you know
if i let's start with some cons actually
so you know then we'll start with some
cons and finish with some good pros you
know
first of all the cons like i said i
don't know if it was a good enough
standalone movie if you haven't seen the
original movie
it was too long it was four hours
nothing could hold your attention for
four hours you know
four hours four hour movie that was long
so i thought it was too long two it was
in the four three dimensions like
regular tv
i couldn't stand that i actually watched
it again on my ipad
and it was much more enjoyable but when
you're watching on your like 4k tv
or you're like a regular dimension tv
16x9
whatever that is you know you're
watching this movie and the sides are
cut off
so you feel like you're missing half the
movie i don't know why they made that
choice
they put a a disclaimer up saying like
you know
to to uh to show snyder's
vision it was it was in this format
but i call [ __ ] i think it was a
money issue
but dude i don't have no idea but the
fact that he even convinced the studio
hey can i do the movie again that's a
pro
let me put that in the pro column
because how many times have you wanted
that
yourself anyway they did this for
superman movie too remember the original
superman
from the 70s the the director of that
he has his own cut of superman 2 i
believe it is that he wanted and it was
all this drama there's a great
documentary about it you know
there was a great i don't know if it was
the official documentary but i saw
something i think it was on youtube and
they were talking about this and it was
a group very fascinating to
hear all the issues and problems they
were having making that movie and
and the directors fighting with the
studio and so all these years later he
got a chance to like do it again so this
is great snyder comes and he says listen
we're in the middle of a pandemic anyway
i guess or maybe they weren't in the
panic at the time but he's like
hey man cause he had to leave the movie
for some reason he never got to finish
it
i believe that's the story but don't
hold me to that
so he comes back and goes i actually can
i finish it can we do it my way can you
give me some money and let me just like
do this again
uh you know and they said okay sure sure
buddy
do do what you want get the actors back
film new scenes
put the movie together the way you want
that is a big pro
because oh man i would love to do that i
would love to take all these new star
wars movies and be like can i do them
again
can i be the editor of these can you do
what i want would that be great if any
of us could do that what would we change
about a movie
so that was fascinating about it that we
got to see this guy's vision of the
movie but you need
the old division of the movie to even
appreciate his vision you get what i'm
saying
so that's why i'm saying it's a
different experience if you've already
seen the movie
and you and you see the new one which i
think is the way to go
even if you saw this one first watch the
old one so you could be like oh
they really changed some stuff so all
right so that's in the con i don't know
if it's a standalone movie
now another thing that uh here's a
here's a quick con i have on my list
that we can talk about i'm gonna jump
all over the place but here's the con
i don't understand the power levels
in the movie meaning how strong is
wonder woman
because sometimes i think she's the most
she's the strongest person in the whole
movie
like is she strong and then you got
superman you know superman like
what is superman's power level what is
wonder woman's power level can wonder
woman hang with superman
because apparently she can you know but
even
they they make it out like she can hang
with him but
but then she can't hang with him you
know it's so weird and then like you
know
um you don't know how strong the villain
is this
steppenwolf whatever his name was to
stefan wolfe
like he was like he reminded me of
thanos because even in the
mcu i was like how [ __ ] strong is
thanos is he like why
he he beating up everybody he can't be
hurt like and then
other times he can be it's so bizarre so
i wish you had a sense of the power
levels and i think this is something
that
this is what's wrong with the superman
character too like this is what i'm
saying too
let's talk about this like superman is a
great character you know i get it it's
like
you know but he's too powerful
it's too godlike you know and that's why
there's nowhere to go in the story
there's no villains that can really
compete they tried to make lex luthor
that's why they have kryptonite you know
without kryptonite
it'd just be a boring guy who could do
anything and he's the strongest
strongest ever and you know what i mean
it's just
a bizarre you know that's why you oh
let's make this little this little thing
kryptonite
makes him the strongest person in the
world okay cool
here's a question i always i want to
pose to you about superman
if the yellow sun of earth
makes people from krypton
gods why the hell didn't they just move
to some place with a yellow sun
because they had all this technology
like if you know the superman lore
you know according to the movies or the
can i don't know what's canon anymore
but
you know apparently superman you know
that that
that ship he came in was you know got
technology from a thousand worlds and
they
you know they have all this knowledge
and information and power and
technology and but you just go to earth
and you could be all then they all
should move to earth
why didn't you know what i mean or they
should be like well maybe we need to
move to a place with a red sun
with a yellow sun because look what it
does to us i mean imagine
it's like it's like if we can go to mars
and on mars
all of a sudden everybody's like super
fit you know the martian air makes you
makes your body go into your the most
optimal you'll be like what what are we
doing here let's go there
but we don't even have the technology to
do that but these the kryptonians
obviously had the technology so
i don't understand that but and like i
say i didn't i don't i think icon is
understanding the power levels like how
strong is aquaman
you know how strong is wonder woman how
strong is superman in comparison to them
and then flash is he just fast or does
he have
power you know and then the cyborg guy
you know you know he he's made from this
thing you know the mother boxes and all
that whatever the hell
that stupidness was
so here's another con about the movie
and it's also a pro i thought it was too
long
and i thought there were too many
stories i thought there were too many
stories
but those too many stories are also a
pro because some of those stories were
fantastic
you know and i thought khan a big con
was that he left us hanging and we
wanted more
i know it sounds like i liked the movie
but i mean
i'm telling you this the um
the too many stories you know because it
was like snyder was like
i want to tell all these stories and and
then like because
i think that he did in this one movie
what
marvel did in 12 years by making a thor
movie
captain america movie captain marvel
movie iron man movies
uh then making like the joint movies you
know the captain america you know the
winter soldier and all this stuff right
they made all the
they set us up for 12 years for this
great finale and i think snyder was like
why don't we do what they're doing
so he sort of set up within this movie
he was telling some backstory he was
showing some
some heart and soul of these characters
why they're the way they are who they
are
and i thought it was great and it was
like beautifully
shot and it was so it was visually
captivating you know
like here's a big pro i like about this
movie compared to the other one all
right
flash in the in the justice league that
came out in 2017 the flash was a [ __ ]
like he just like they just set him up
to be
he wasn't a hero they completely took
that out
they took it out he was a straight-up
stud in this movie
all right and they had this great scene
of like showcasing
um you know the visual effects and
showcasing his
power in the same way they did in um in
x-men
x-men did it first you know x-men first
class with quicksilver
in x-men you know the scene where he's
running so fast that everything's in
slow motion
they did the same thing with the flash
and it was great
and it made me be like i'd watch a
standalone movie with flash like i want
to see the flash movie with this guy
he's a much more interesting character
now you know i i
the the this thing with his father being
in jail and and
being accused of the death of his mom
and how he's trying to like
get into law so he can like of you know
he could he can get his father off and
all of that stuff was like i it
it was more it was just more captivating
it was more
interesting than when you made him a
hero
so i really liked that change that's one
of the changes that i really liked and
like i say
this little snippet this little of the
movie like really getting you into who
flash is and
showing his power and they show this
girl that like obviously you'd be like
oh this is gonna be a good spin up
that's gonna be the love interest maybe
and they're gonna do this other flash
movie and the way he did it in this
movie
i'm down i'm like let me see let me see
a flash movie so
that was a big con that i really liked a
pro i'm sorry that was a big pro
um i really i really like that a lot
um let me see what else do i got here
uh i thought i thought overall it was a
better story
i thought overall what he added because
the original villain the stefan wolfe in
the in the original
the guy he was too like a cartoon
character he wasn't
just you you know you it kind of felt
the same as like
whatever was going on in that wonder
woman movie there was one of these
movies where it was kind of the same
thing
you know and i was like oh they're doing
this again so he really upgraded the
villain he was
menacing and like you know the the metal
armor and his
voice was better and he was just like i
was a little bit like ooh this guy's a
badass right
so i did i did enjoy that
um you know and like i say the
individual stories you wanted more so i
i liked that change
the overall story was better and then he
added um
what is it uh deathstroke or not
deathstroke
but he added the main marvel villain you
know i wish i would have wrote that down
look at me i'm an old man i'm forgetting
stuff but you know you you saw this
overall villain you know who was like
within the comic books within dc
this guy is like the the oh the main bad
guy he's like the thanos
of the of the dc world and now you see
like oh okay they're setting it up where
they have to you know they're going to
eventually have to go get this guy and i
thought
he did a good job of being like hey i
want to see this continued
you know let's see what's going on past
that
so what is that guy's name i know you
guys are saying it in the chat right now
you know maybe i should just look it up
because it's going to drive us
it's going to drive me crazy for the
rest of the uh you know
how should i google main villain um
let's see justice league
villains you know what i mean
you know let's see um dark side
thank you thank you anyway yeah so dark
side is this like thanos type character
he's like the
the one who sent stuff and wolf to like
get these mother boxes
i'm not gonna spoil the ruler i should
have said spoiler alert from the
beginning but
so now it gave more context to
you know what's happening why why are
they coming to earth why you know why is
all this happening he snyder made it
like makes
more sense you know than the original
movie so i liked that
that was a pro one of the big pros i
liked about this movie but it's also a
con
is it was grimier man it was gritty they
were cursing they dropped f-bombs all
over the movie
there was blood you know but
what went wrong is the fact that they
didn't film it as deadpool
like as a like if it was a rated r
justice league
i'm on board 100
but they didn't do that but he added
that element
so it was a lot grimier and grittier and
a little more violent more
graphic it was more graphic but not
graphic enough because if they didn't
have enough footage to be
full on graphic but he he toned down the
cartooniness like
the wonder woman scene you know when you
first see wonder woman in the movie
you know you know she's foiling a
terrorist attack
and she she beats these people
up like it's violent you know heads
crash against
the thing and you get a sense that oh
that guy might be dead you know
i did think it was unnecessary i think
it was overkill though
like the final villain he tries to shoot
all these people
and she like blocks all the bullets
wonder woman's style you know then she
gets up and goes like i don't believe it
and she's like
you believe it or whatever catch phrase
she says and then she
slams her to you know that little move
she does it's like the hulk
it's like the hulk one you know she
slams her two like
bracelets together and this sonic boom
of power blasts out
i'm like she blasted this dude broke
i mean the property damage was
unbelievable
you know what i mean like wonder woman
what you doing just disarm this dude
hit him with the lasso you know you got
super speed
zoom over there take the gun out of his
hand and and knock him out
no she did the bracelets and blew a hole
through the whole thing
blew a hole through the whole building
everybody's outside like whoa
what the hell is going on i mean
somebody's gonna have to be accountable
for that
the people that own that building gonna
be like hey [ __ ]
what's up with the uh why didn't you
just
why did you just disarm him why you
gotta do all this property damage
so i thought that kind of stuff was like
come on that was unnecessary
especially when within the movie
universe
that was a big thing they were getting
on superman about that like yo bro
like i think like two billion peop two
million people are dead in uh
in metropolis like you know when you had
a little fight with zod
you know you did like trillion dollars
worth of damage can we talk about this
you know they made that a part of the
movie and i thought that was great
so again i think that
even even they even made one because one
of them is already a great movie a great
character
she's great i love her she's believable
everything's believable about her you
know
she's so beautiful and fierce you know
and um they made her even more
interesting he made
he made that part more interesting you
know and here's another one that i
thought was a pro
con con pro was the the music i mean
some of the music was just out of place
over dramatic
uh it was it was just i don't know in
some places i thought it was nice like
when that visual scene of flash when
everything's in slow motion i was like
oh this is a nice choice
and then other times i'm like why is
this sort of gloomy-ass
gothic music playing so some of it was
weird you know what i mean so
which made it like i don't know if it
was it was good or bad but like i said
these individual stories so getting back
to that the individual stories so the
flash story
great loved it want to see more we
already see in wonder woman movies
great boom um but
they finally went into like i think the
guy's cyborg i think that's what his
name is
i don't know but anyway the black dude
whose father
you know turned him into a cyborg
because he was in an accident he used
this
motherbox machine that the villains were
trying to get to
you know bring him back to life and he's
got all this cyborg power and he's like
great with machines and whatnot
but they started to give you a little
backstory on him a little context on his
story
and i thought oh this is nice this is
what was needed this is what you know
the iron man movies captain america
movies
all those movies gave you gave us
backstory the hulk movies you know it
gave us backstory so we can like
you know be invested in the characters
so he really took some time to get
invested in these characters and i
really liked that
so i thought that guy's story was good i
thought the flash story was good i
thought
adding more to who wonder woman is i
thought all that stuff was good
here's a big change that they made pro
con is you know they took out this thing
about batman being like
how batman is trying to kill himself or
batman is like
sacrificing his life they completely
took that out too
they took that out you know oh aquaman
two by the way they gave some more
context to who about aquaman's story and
what's going on at atlantis and all that
kind of stuff so
but we already have an aquaman movie and
you know they think they're doing
another one so
but they gave some more contacts and i
thought it was nice you know i thought
all these little extra stories it just
made the movie too damn long
you know but um
yeah so you know
so you you know so you have like all
these different stories like you know
coalescing you know they're coming
together and like making this movie but
it just was
i don't know i don't know man
but i did like again i did like all of
the little stories
to help push the story along so they
took out that nonsense about
the flash being a coward they took that
out they made him a hero
they took out batman
like being like ah i messed up
i'm terrible so i'm gonna like sacrifice
myself for these people they took all
that out
they took out some some things in the
story you know they made it again it was
more grimy it was more it was more
violent and graphic you know so
i did like that um
you can understand the villain that's
another thing i wrote i know that i
wrote to myself
because in the original movie he was
like his accent was so thick it reminded
me of like
bane or something where i was like they
probably you know an application they
probably thought this was cool
but for like two hours of a four-hour
movie if you can't understand
a character you're like what and this
this character i got his purpose and
like his voice was good it was scary it
was menacing so i thought that was good
all right let me get to something here
that i thought was
like you could skip ahead to this and be
satisfied
like i would like the whole four hours
wasn't as good as the last five minutes
of this movie
okay like spoiler alert right now
so you might want to skip ahead
let's give ahead like five minutes or
something because
all right at the end of this movie all
right
there is a conversation between batman
played by ben affleck and the joker
in their universe played by jared leto
and that [ __ ] is fantastic
like it is such a great exchange
that i want to see that movie
like whatever is because this was like a
dream
where they they did this in the first
movie too
and and this is part of the the dc lore
i believe too
like lois lane dies somehow she dies
and superman can't take it and he goes
crazy
he becomes the thing that batman thought
he would become
that he would become this overlord
dictator and we all have to cower to him
he becomes that you know and superman
blames everybody for lois lane's death
especially bruce wayne it makes no sense
that superman can't find them
i feel like he could just fly to the sky
and x-ray vision just look until they
find him but
i don't know super hearing he knows what
their voices sound like
didn't make any sense that he couldn't
find him so
it's in this kind of post-apocalyptic
world
uh in batman's dream or if it's a
premonition
and there's this like i'm telling you
just
dynamic explosive exchange
like ben affleck i wish he was still
batman
he is dope batman say what you want
about him he was a terrible
daredevil but he's a dope ass batman
this exchange he has with jared leto and
jared leto
let me just say this whatever he didn't
do
for the joker character in the original
movie in um
in the what is it i forgot the name of
the the whatever that movie is they did
with the harley quinn and all that i
think that he and then
after seeing after seeing the new joker
after seeing like you know
people talk about him and then knowing
that heath ledger you know how he led
you did it and
i think for this part of the movie
he went to town on this and did a
i mean it was a great joker
and to me it was the best part of the
movie
you know i it it was the one part of the
movie that i perked up and this is after
four hours rob's like damn that's good
just their exchange was just i'm telling
you right now you can skip ahead to it
right now and you'll enjoy it you know
because it has nothing to do with
everything that happened in in the
justice league
like it literally has nothing to do with
justice league it has something to do
with like
and and what i l and what i'm sad about
is i want more of this i want to see
this continued i want snyder to
i hope the studio goes okay people
really liked this
why don't you continue man let's get
everybody let's get the band back
together and do this again
because i i don't know i think it's
i think it's completely worth it so
that was the spoiler for that um yeah
man
i mean i guess i could say a lot more
but i don't know i guess people ask do
you need to see the original justice
league
to enjoy this i don't think you do but i
think you should
that's my my last advice for that i
think you should
so i think i covered all my points i
wanted to cover about the movie
um but i and i can't reiterate enough
that the ending of that movie is just
fantastic there's just a that's just an
explosive exchange between two
two two pretty good actors you know so
one time i saw ben now i was like
and i wish like i wish they would let
ben affleck
actually write and direct uh like a
grimy
deadpool type rated r batman movie you
know
cuz man whoo i can't tell you enough
it's worth going to watch to check that
out
all right yeah baby i think that's it
about uh justice league for now
huh i really think i went into it enough
if you have questions if you want to
talk about it more
you know hit me up in the comments hit
me up on netflix i'm not netflix hit me
up on instagram
and you know maybe i'll talk about it
again next week maybe i'll get some
questions in the instagram may put up a
question
what do you want me to talk about with
justice league again because you know
it's worth it it's
what's what's happening right now and
i'm a super nerd i like the superhero
movies and all that kind of stuff
so that being said let me do a quick
brief um of what i thought of falcon
and the winter soldier dudes
let me tell you i don't know if i want
to see a movie again
because i want i want this
this if they're gonna spend the money if
they're gonna spend movie money
to make eight episode series
and really get into the nitty-gritty
build the universe and they're gonna do
it in that mcu style
i'm 100 for it because
listen i really i enjoyed wanda vision
especially the later episodes when they
really started to delve into like who is
wanda and
what what happened and what's going on i
thought it was great
this started fantastic it's well made
the special effects are dope it's it's
the actors from the movies too so it's
great um
you know what i mean so
i i i i just there were
there was one thing though there there
was one thing about
um um falcon in the um
winter soldier that i
i was like hmm they made a mistake here
and that's with don cheeto don cheato i
don't know how to say his last name
his character you know he plays the iron
guy he's not supposed to be able to he's
supposed to have
fake legs and they didn't do that in the
movie he in this
in the show he ain't supposed to have
his legs
remember he hurt himself in one of those
movies in civil war
and then stark gave him the fake legs he
didn't have a fake legs in the movie
that was an error
you know it could correct me from wrong
but that was an error but anyways
falcon and winter soldier it was great
you're really getting into
and sebastian whatever his last name is
he was on him dying up here too
you know he's such he's really a great
actor you know so him as the winter
soldier
seeing him like that's what you want to
know like how does the winter soldier
after everything that happened to him
knowing his history that he was like
he's been alive for a hundred years
he's been a killer he's been controlled
by some evil organization
how does someone come to terms with that
about themselves i love that they're
exploring that he's in therapy and he's
trying to like
you know he's trying to like you know
figure out who he is now and i loved it
you know and it was still
violent and you know it's adult and i
just
it's worth to watch i hope that the rest
of the
the series continues in the same way but
for now
they did a fantastic job
so thumbs up for me on
um falcon in the winter soldier episode
one
because again too they're delving into
this
people were gone for five years and how
did that affect people's life i mean
because remember falcon was gone he
disappeared for five years now when he
comes back he's like damn
my nephews and nieces are like now
they're five years older you know
my sister was struggling with paying the
bills and and so now i'm here to try to
help but she don't want my help and it's
like
they're delving into all that and i just
think oh man this is great
you can't get into this when you're
doing a two-hour movie even a three-hour
movie
but you can when you're doing like you
know hours of a television show
i think it's much better to the point
where
even if they made like it would be dope
if they made like hour-long
episodes that you had to go watch in the
theater
i mean i think i would even do that you
know what i mean like let's say they had
like
you know you had to go to the movie
theater
if you really wanted that experience and
you got to go see
you know then maybe they showed you like
some other stuff or whatever
but you know it's just because i don't
know how they justify
the money they spend to make it do they
get that money back but then look at
netflix they may go they spend all that
money
so i don't know uh like i say thumbs up
winter soldier it's a falcon in the
winter soldier so check that out all
right guys
anyways thank you for watching uh we're
filming with griffin
and uh shout out to my sponsors
betterhelp.com remember that's
betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
griffin and of course helix sleep
get the best sleep of your life so check
those guys
both those things out you can see all
the stuff in the description
and you know i'll be back uh rachel will
be back real well advice from the grown
grown-ass man i'll be back
and i'll keep you posted about what's
going on uh with this process of me
doing this new great fantastic job that
i hope they announced
today so you know what i'm talking about
but if not they will soon
and i don't know i still enjoy doing
this
i'm feeling comfortable with it even
more so after 100 something episodes i'm
really comfortable i'm i'm fine with
the level that it's at right now and
hopefully it'll grow if it doesn't i
still appreciate everybody that's been
here that is here all the time
every single week so thank you and i
will see you
next week
you